are humans the only species that use
dopamine
and does evolutionary biology have
anything interesting to say about
dopamine and social media
i meant to actually uh look this up to
make sure but i believe
that dopamine dopamine is at least as
old as vertebrates and it may
actually extend far far
older than that into the into the
history of animals
so certainly certainly it's not just
humans or primates or mammals
it's at least all vertebrates and maybe
far far alert than that
right but what that means and what that
doesn't mean um
is a little bit tougher puzzled so
you get into this with actually peterson
and his uh the reason that he is
associated with lobsters
is that his point is that serotonin i
believe is associated with
uh dominance hierarchies and it goes
back to our branching point with the
crustaceans
um and so at least that's where it goes
back right so his point is this isn't a
human thing get over it right this is a
really really ancient thing and his
point is right about this
now the problem though if you want to
challenge it
is these molecules are
part of an agreement right a physical
agreement
the molecule be it a hormone
uh or a pheromone is a molecule
built to trigger a receptor when it hits
it because it has the right
shape and the right configuration of
charges on its surface
it could be anything right so you could
take
dopamine and you could engineer a system
in which dopamine did serotonin's job
and serotonin did dopamine's job
and it would work just as well because
the point is well it's actually like
this
when you hit yourself in the eye and you
see light why did you see light there's
no light
right you see light because those are
light receptors and you've triggered
them with pressure but they
detect it as light because they send the
message to the part of the brain that
detects light
and so the point is what it's wired to
is what dictates what it does not the
shape of the molecule the molecule is
totally arbitrary so so in the case of
for instance peterson's lobsters um
serotonin is both h is ancient and
hierarchies are ancient and the link
between those two
also turns out to be ancient but that
third thing isn't inherently true just
because the first two things are true
right it doesn't have to be true right
one of two things
it is in this case right but right it
could be that
um the molecule was associated with
hierarchies and lobsters and is
associated in
with hierarchies in us but that wasn't a
continuous process or it can be
that it was continuous but it doesn't it
doesn't really matter in case of
dopamine
it will serve a very similar function
for
many many ancestors right so back
probably through all of mammals dopamine
is going to play a reward uh
role does it play that reward role you
know
in vertebrates deeper than that i don't
know i i would guess it probably does
yeah that'd be my guess too but i don't
know
but it doesn't really matter yes very
ancient not not about humans in the
slightest yeah
so the second part of that question
which we're probably spending too long
on these early questions
is does evolutionary biology have
anything interesting to say about
dopamine and social media
um well yeah
obviously a mechanism
that causes you to release dopamine
captures your attention
and tends to get you focused on it
um so for example you know
a would-be lover who
tantalizes you such that you feel
rewarded for being in their presence
right captures your attention and makes
it harder for somebody else to get your
attention
so that can be a game now in that case
it's a natural game and you may have an
interest in
playing along in the case of the
social media platforms they have
gamified
their war with each other in order to
keep you on site
they have figured out how to trigger
rewards that shouldn't be triggered in
you so
it may be that you should go out and do
some exercise
and go encounter something real but
facebook
is tricking you into staying on facebook
by making you feel as if you're doing
something that's good for you
and it causes self-harm and so anyway
tristan harris would be the go-to guy on
this question
we should have him on the podcast oh
absolutely for sure but
um yes so it does have something to say
mostly what it says is that this
endogenous system is being gamed for
somebody else's advantage